[Music]
so he'd think about investing today it
tends to be all about outperforming the
market it tends to be about making more
money and it tends to be about picking
and choosing the right stock the right
mutual fund mutual fund versus in ETF
the right money manager and that has
worked I was going to say well for the
population but frankly has worked ok for
the population why because the goal that
the industry said itself a long time ago
of active management and outperforming
the market well less than 1% well less
than half a percent of money managers
outperform the market consistently over
any 5-year period ok so back up when we
did our research with women the concept
of beating the market fell completely
flat the concept of winning fell flat in
in fact even the concept of making more
money felt pretty flat sort of
surprisingly it seemed like a pretty
good goal what worked for women were
actual goals so ok if I'm gonna put my
money aside and invest my money I want
to be able to an X number of years buy
my dream home have a child start a
business retire well take that trip
around the world that I wanted to and so
we found that women tend to be more
goals oriented and focused than men
another finding for us men tend to if
you ask them the question about their
risk tolerance which by the way the
whole industry does men will answer by
the way they don't know what it is we
only ever learn what our risk tolerance
is really when we go through downturns
but women we found were oh oh my gosh
you know what I'm gonna think about that
let me think about that and I'll get
back to you and they never do it really
shuts down the conversation and so we
instead of asking a question we know
people don't have the wherewithal to
answer instead we said ok let us learn
about you through the taking you through
the
and the capability tell us what your
goals are and then we'll tell you
essentially how much much risk you can
afford so for an example you and I are
the same person we make the same salary
we have the same level of education
we're the same age and you don't have an
emergency fund so you don't have cash
set aside for a rainy rainy day anyone
have a baby in four years I just need to
retire right it doesn't really matter
what I think my risk tolerance is you
don't get a lot of risk I get plenty of
risk and so we tweaked things like that
as well as really making it so making it
goals based approaching risk differently
taking into account again that women
live longer and salaries peak soon are
forecasting out their their life curves
and then the most important change we
found is that most people think of and
describe women as risk-averse investors
what we found may be a subtle point as
women are risk aware investors and what
they wanted was not hey explain risk to
me in standard deviation and let's
really go through that statistical
analysis but more hold on how bad can it
get and so what we do is we track you
track women to their goal and say in X
percent of markets it could be this bad
and why $0.04 that bad and if you fall
off track if you fall off track to
reaching your goal will reach out to you
tell you're off track and tell you what
you have to do to get back on deposit
another thousand dollars retire six
months later so those are a few of the
differences some of which are
straightforward and others of which are
more subtle that we found were barriers
from keeping women to keeping women from
investing so I'm the co-founder and CEO
of Ella best which is a digital
investment platform for women if you had
told me a couple of years ago that I
should build a digital investment
platform for women I would have told you
you were sexist I would have told you it
was a really stupid idea and I would
have probably been somewhat disdainful
to you about it and what I said what do
you know women don't need anything
different for men you know what do you
think our lady brains can't handle the
big man Bray
numbers but then but then one morning I
had an insight which is the retirement
savings crisis in this country is really
a woman's issue and a woman's crisis we
retire with two thirds the money of men
and we live six to eight years longer
80% of nursing home residents are women
so it really is while we're not used to
thinking about it through a gendered
perspective it is really a woman's issue
that changes the solutions they go from
being all about tax increases and
entitlement cuts to being about women
having more money so how do we get women
more money well there are a lot of
people working on the gender pay gap and
the gender work achievement gap but it
struck me at about the same time that
there's a gender investing gap that we
cost women hundreds of thousands of
dollars some women millions of dollars
over the course of their lives because
they don't invest as much as men do we
women tend to blame ourselves
I need more financial education I really
need to dig in and do this I just have
to find the right company but it struck
me as I sort of dug into it then maybe
the problem is not ours as women maybe
the challenge is that it's an industry
that's by men for men that 86% of
financial advisors are men and that
number is held steady for forever and as
a result it just fits men better the the
words they use beat the market
outperform pick a winner are words of
war and sports the investing TV is like
watching sports Sunday and the industry
symbol is a bowl so it's a phallic
symbol so in every way it's sort of set
for men include the fact that men will
invest through jargon and women won't
and you have an industry that doesn't
feel right for women so we decided to
dig in and change not just the marketing
lots of people market to women but the
underlying product as well to take into
account what we were learning about
women and how they invest and to take
into account the fact that we live
longer that's important when you're
forecasting how much income you need for
retirement our salaries peak sooner
that's completely unfair but is
important when it
to gather financial and investing plans
[Music]